why do so many people at least the ones
who are active on twitter why do they
feel so like anti-business i think it's
our arts our conditioning that's what we
were taught
yeah that making money people have so
many i'm sure you see this all the time
so many limiting beliefs around making
money you know making money means you
are compromising your integrity making
money means you're taking advantage of
people making money means you are losing
yourself and not being authentic we all
have these we never actually completely
let go of all those beliefs they're
lurking back here in our psychology but
those things you know they have truth in
them but they're not the truth yeah like
money is the root of all evil yeah kind
of stuff yeah
yeah i remember
two years ago now or a year and a half
ago uh i had a call with you and our
mutual friend david about
this course that i was i was gonna start
at the part-time youtuber academy and i
was thinking oh you know i'll do it as a
pre-recorded thing i'll sell it for like
200 why don't we partner up on it
because i don't like the idea of selling
it myself but if i sell it with you then
it's like it makes it okay
and what you and david were both kind of
laughing it was like it sounds like you
think making money is evil yeah it
sounds like you think selling something
is evil yeah but what if that's not true
and you sort of challenged me to
question my assumptions around that yeah
that actually what is money money is an
exchange of value yeah and if you're
providing something that is valuable and
doing it in a way that's like authentic
and in with integrity and stuff yeah and
people pay you for it that's literally
how the world runs yeah and that is not
an evil thing and there are so many
creators that i speak to now that i i
recount that conversation too and
they're like ah it's okay for me to get
to do a sponsored video sponsored by
squarespace or brilliant or skillshare
whoever happens to be sponsoring this
headset but as soon as i sell my own
products suddenly that becomes oh i i
couldn't do that yeah my audience would
hate me for becoming a sellout for
selling my own thing yeah yeah and the
internet almost makes this worse because
you can just create free stuff forever
and you'll get paid somehow maybe like
sponsorships or you know ads or
something it's just a certain business
model that we both found finding the
most engaged people who are building
their own businesses can can really be a
great business and really impactful for
them like we were talking before
recording that
someone can hear a piece of advice a
hundred times but then you look them in
the eye and you say do x
x is the right path for you and suddenly
they're like oh wow that really sunk in
it's the power of teaching it's the
power of coaching it's the power of
interactive you know forums
yeah
nice hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day